he's deported more illegal immigrants he
has deported more people and then at the
same time he's doing deferred action for
dreamers so it's there's always a mixed
pot that we get we can never seem to get
someone to stand a hundred percent and
do the right thing and I think that's
why it's necessary to be here I'm
undocumented and I came here with the
other writers of the undocumented status
filled with undocumented youth parents
grandparents who are traveling across
the country from Phoenix Arizona here to
Charlotte North Carolina to come to the
Democratic National Convention and make
sure the president understands that
regardless of the results of the
election we need him to know that he has
deported more people when Obama was
elected he promised the community our
reform we know see that he has the power
to decide and we want him to decide on
one side on his
making sure your faces your stories your
situation physics and so things will
change we're here with you are you
disappointed with how the democrats and
obama have treated the immigration issue
i mean i think on all sides everyone has
really dropped the ball and you know and
we did we were able to pass the DREAM
Act but it didn't get through the Senate
it's just one of those things where we
really need to have better
representation and that's why we
continue to have to keep seeing soldiers
of the battle keep going down one by one
until finally there's a there's a
critical mass I mean he used to he's
deported more illegal immigrant he has
deported more people and then at the
same time he's doing deferred action for
dreamers so it's there's always a mixed
pot that we get we can never seem to get
someone to stand 100% and do the right
thing and I think that's why it's
necessary to be here and be talking
about those issues and it's not just
people with microphones and inside you
get to say something and get to go home
and not hear anything people need to
listen as well and this is them making
an effort to be heard and I think that's
really powerful I'm happy to be here
you